and new tonight here at 11 o'clock
combating food insecurity
that's the goal of a federal program
that's working to create an agriculture
park and a food co-op
in the historic west side of las vegas
but there's some controversy about the
location arko mana joining us in studio
tonight with concerns from community
organizers orca
well denise the co-op will be located
inside james gate park which is located
on the eastern edge of the historic west
side community it's one of 13 spots
elected nationwide
for the program but community organizers
tell me there are better locations
just feet away i remember
what it was like to be in my
neighborhood with kids who
were hungry food insecurity is a big
issue in las vegas
historic west side community but there
will soon be a new way to address it
james gay park which has been closed for
years will turn into an urban
agriculture park and co-op where food
will be grown
prepared and sold to people who live
here it's part of local foods local
places a federal program by the epa and
department of agriculture
i love the idea of having an actual food
co-op in our
in our neighborhood but community
organizer tashika lawson has concerns
about the location
i don't think that you should have to
take an actual asset
like this park from this community
to be able to give food security lawson
says the park should reopen as a place
for kids to play instead
she wants to see the co-op replace what
she calls a troubled grocery store in
the area
or these empty lots we have vacant land
literally like right across the street
other organizers agree
still they're happy some progress is
being made and hope it's a springboard
to address
other issues we need businesses over
here we need to help these people with
these houses
we need to get these abandoned lots
cleaned up i commend the city's effort
i just wish they were doing it more
sensitively
the epa adds that the agriculture park
in cooper
on the west side will also include an
education center and an outdoor
community area live in the studio
tonight orca mana 8 news now